okay so just so I know who that I'm
making eye contact with who wasn't able
to get this question yesterday the
challenge question heads up straight so
I can see no yeah okay so have you got
it and didn't show me right that's why
like I said I'm gonna show you two ways
tree the passed away first
okay but as is often the problem right
when you read a solution or something or
you someone shows you the solution or
something I it only works really well
with that particular question and then
you meet one and it's slightly different
they they shift around some of the piece
of information data that they give you
this approach doesn't magically work and
you need something else so I'm gonna
show you two ways to approach it and the
first way is faster but the second way
might apply to different kind of
situations where you get different
information okay now the first challenge
of the question was just to decode what
it meant okay and often this is what
happens in your last questions you know
a lot of you have come to me with the
trial pips from other schools and stuff
and you're like I don't even know how to
do this question and then when I explain
what it means you're like oh I could do
that I can throw the kind of hat okay so
let's try and decode it first and then
you might find you're like I think I
know how to hey Lois for this parabola
here okay which is almost the general
problem it's just we've locked it in it
equals one might as well know down
equals one does that tell you
it tells you it's gonna be concave up
and it also locks in the UH the
steepness of the parabola because if you
muck around with B and C I'm not sure if
I'll show this to you before but all it
does is really just changes the position
okay show that the distance D between
the vertex and the x-axis okay so stop
right before you move any further just
get the picture in your head this
distance between the verdicts and the
x-axis what is that look like well
because I know that it's going to be
concave up and there's a certain kind of
steepness to it that distance is from
here the vertex right to the x-axis
that's the distance okay and seeing is
it's just a perpendicular distance right
what I really want is if I can just work
out the y-coordinates of
okay in this case that's going to be the
negative off the distance that I'm after
okay so good that's in place that's
that's the D but I'm laughter sure this
is D is proportional to okay stop
what's that mean is proportional to what
does it mean when things are in
proportion if you remember any of this
from people who were hearing your
tendons in variation that were your
topic what does it mean for things to be
in proportion it means when something
crores
the other thing grows with it okay and
not just it grows with it but they grow
at the same rate okay so for instance if
you buy I'm trying to think of something
where you don't get like benefits from
the more that she gets you know if I get
one donut okay it might be something
absorbent like a dollar 20 okay and you
know sometimes this will get cheaper but
mine's really yeah they're been nasty so
you buy two Donuts
and they're like we do not reward
beautiful loyalty it's the same price
okay so these are in proportion to one
another right it's like no the more its
yeah it stop eating Donuts we better you
know that's right all right so these are
unfortunate to each other right and this
is kind of if you call that in like
number of donuts right and this is say
Peter price okay this is clearly one
point sorry all around No
and it was 1.2 sorry yeah but use that
okay now if I can establish this kind of
relationship I can say that they are
proportional to each other right there's
a nice fancy way of writing it using
something which looks like an alpha but
it's not really but this means and it's
unfortunate big piece and unfortunate
and doesn't matter what the proportion
is the what I'm after is that they are
proportion and then what are we for
questioning between the square the
distance between the roots okay
square the distance between the roots so
if I can work out what this is and now
it hasn't been given a name so I'm going
to give it a name let's call it say okay
write the square the distance between
the roots that we can't square okay so
what I want to end on is something like
D being proportional to K square okay
or you know going back a liar D be equal
to something times K squared once I
establish that that's what I've actually
been asked to prove okay so now having
done that decoding how we gonna go about
it Sylvia well I think that the first
simplest way is to say well let's get it
let's do it in order okay so what's D
it's gonna be this distance here right
now if I want to get the Y cornets the
fastest way to get there is to see that
the vertex lies on the axis of symmetry
axis of symmetry
what is the axis of symmetry of the
parabola
the axis of symmetry it's this is the
x-coordinate usually okay because it's
very cool it's - must be a - a right and
if you have trouble remembering this
because some of you we're struggling
with this because you remembered the
wrong line and you mix it up with some
practice routes so the way I remember it
is I think I'll say mr. Serb perform
like whoa Jake formula works and
formulas for finding the two solutions
this guy and this guy okay
it starts with this minus B onto a and
then it's plus or minus the square root
of the discriminant on 2n now because
they both want to way we usually you
know Chuck them together in one fraction
but writing it as two fractions makes it
a little clearer you've got this central
line and then you go forward a little
bit some distance to get to one room and
backwards to get to the other one put it
symmetrical okay so that's how I
remember it's my spins way and don't
make something - be on a which is this
so if that's what it is it's actually
just - parity because we know what the
value of a is right so if that's where
the axis of symmetry is so it goes
through the vertex I just need to stop
that in right I'm gonna stop that India
now to give you the y-coordinate okay so
if I say the y-coordinate of the vertex
okay just a straight substitution so
we're gonna get B squared plus this okay
so we're just tidy up a little bit this
is minus b squared on - so that's like a
quarter - a five so it's coming - a
quarter so okay now if that's the
y-coordinate okay you've got two options
here you can either reason geometrically
and you can say given the kind of
parabola that I've got right
this must be below the axis okay and so
D is just negative that to intercept a
minus sign in front but you gotta
explain why alternatively you can just
sign and that's
okay but you do have to be careful with
absolute value science right there you
can't just put them on and take them off
willy-nilly okay so some of you when
you're already a solution take note of
where you've put absolute value signs
are not taking them off you have to be
requesters with them especially if it's
a you know right so of that D what's
left is to find the distance between the
roots and then I will square that okay
so where are the roots well they're
these two guys right and I can use the
quadratic formula but the distance
between them we're just talking about
this right the distance between them is
based on this thing right this is your
absolute symmetry and you have to go
forwards this amount and backwards this
amount so the distance is just double
this isn't it
just two times that so I've caught it
I've caught a camp right so K is going
to be two times the square root of B
squared minus now 4ac a is 1 or C all
over 2a but that's just 2 so those twos
cancel out and what I want is K squared
right now even though in some respects I
don't need to it's in my interests to
slap an absolute value sign on this
because I haven't had to decide on what
I want to prove right and I can say it's
an absolute value because it's going to
be positive right K squared is going to
be what so this is fine okay
now you look at this and you look at
where I'm trying to head right and do
you see this kind of like a mmm there's
a bit of a disjoint right because
they're not in the right order not in
the right order so what do you do
I mean he's one of the army this is
usually annoying for us it means you've
got to go into cases in that company but
in this case it's really useful if you
couldn't absolute value here right so if
I had the absolute value of say M minus
n by definition that's also equal to the
absolute value of n - and these are the
same thing right because one of the very
first definitions we learn - as you know
is it gives you the distance between two
values m and n whatever that distance is
okay so being that what this
algebraically means is I can just shift
this order and play around and do
whatever I like right this B Square - 4
C it's the same as 4 C minus B Square
yeah you take you four out of that
that's C minus and B squared or 4 and I
can take that out because it's positive
no big deal ok and that's 4 D okay so
I'm there K squared must be proportional
to the distance D